je voudrais que comme ton personnage
phare serge le mytho je vais te le sida
y aurait dit j'ai dit que j'avais 36 ans
bientôt 38 et en fait j'ai menti j'ai 40
ans je vais donc vous lancer sur des
anecdotes et vous en bon mito je vous
laisse vous en dire plus c'est ce que
j'ai eus effect moi en voiture
ayew ça fait donc pas me donner
passionata bien vu que le cerveau y
avait de l'eau dedans marque on vous
aperçu avec kim kardashian super u de
guingamp c'est quoi cette histoire avec
kim qui relâchent écoute
kim kardashian moi ça fait longtemps fin
ça fait longtemps que je bosse pour elle
tu as gens enfin page en secret mais où
je suis va lâcher je m'occupe de
résoudre des enquêtes et tu sais qu'elle
s'est fait quand même tapé ses bijoux
moi je sais c'est une vraie histoire
café du un vrai boom dans le métier est
fait dans l'histoire pourtant j'étais
pas dans l'histoire mais j'ai débusquer
les gars rien hein qui travaillait au
super u donc on a fait tous les super u
de france bien sûr
ayant la trouver hello guys in et
travailler aux légumes
reda est tous super u lugano le galway
et c'est un braqueur vendeur de légumes
non ce qui arrive de plus en plus
souvent mais c'est sûr et ça c'est vrai
que ça devient long et court à données
courantes
je veux juste pour être juste pour le
kiff à la semaine dernière il paraît que
tu temps brouillé avec jason statham
dans une bibliothèque web ce s'arranger
ouais voulait prendre le dernier marc
lévy qui avait dans le driving season
tu sais même pas l'air français qu'est
ce tu me casses les couilles we fuck you
et tout ça on est pas on est parti sur
les mains et les pieds
et voilà du temps soit peu voilà quoi
c'est vrai ouais mais s'il ya sans doute
mais si l'histoire de ouf on appelle son
agent qui va aussi continuer jonathan
kent après j'ai appris à jouer après
j'ai appelé himself tu sais ce qu'est ce
que je dis ouais c'est la dernière fois
qu'ils me dit faux culs membres